cette deuxième semaine de compétition
était moins éprouvante que la première
pour louis burton
cette fois ci pas de casse ni de faux
départ le skipper originaire de
rambouillet avance dans l'océan
atlantique en direction de l'équateur à
bord de son imoca bureau vallée deux
navigateurs profit des conditions
climatiques plus clémentes
quand on arrive dans là l'idée sur dur
au mal
c'est les repas parce qu'on passe en
bonne salade n'était alors que en france
en train de manger des tartiflettes
et voilà vous
magnifique salle du jardin avec bris des
vitres à des champignons de paris du
maïs
les maisons on va l'agrémenter
de magnifiques
le choix est
dans la même journée louis burton a jeté
des capteurs dans l'océan pour
recueillir des données océanographiques
à partenariats créés entre son sponsor
la classe imoca et l'unesco
le lendemain le décor est moins
idyllique louis burton affronte le très
redouté pot-au-noir une zone de
convergence inter tropicale au large de
la côte ouest africaine
un secteur instable
gala
voilà
waouh
sacré poteau mort quand même après 13
jours de course louis burton est
toujours sixième du classement mais
remonte sur les premiers le vendée globe
2020 est toujours dominé par le
britannique alex thomson sur hugo boss